allô oui bonjour madame c'est les
coursiers de france 2 oui oui bonjour
madame je suis j'en une mièvre
j'ai pas si thierry beccaro vous a parlé
de moi à oui bon droit mais vous êtes
courtier fait un voilà voilà voilà
alors qu'est ce qui vous a dit thierry
oui mais que vous étiez que vous
travaillez oui et que vous étiez copier
oui et que vous soyez intéressé pour
travailler un peu oui
et que vous faites comment raisonnable
dans les prix à huile à leeds as oui ça
je lui ai dit pas le mentionner mais il
vous a dit ça
oui programmatique qui dit tout ça alors
on écoutait la moitié ouais
après voilà bah oui j'imagine
qu'est ce qui vous a dit d'autres atouts
avant d'accord il n'a pas parlé des
accidents quoi bein fasse taire que suri
j'ai beaucoup de mal à trouver du
travail en ce moment parce que je suis
conseiller dans ce moment chez speedo
2000 et je viens de plier mon septième
scooter mais thierry m'a dit que c'était
pas grave parce que avec lui normalement
je pourrais certainement trouver du
boulot à france2 quoi il faut pas
normalement on trouve pas du boulot
comme celui dit surtout vous lui dites
pas que je vais lui trouver du boulot
ah bah il m'a dit le contraire ah je
vous promets je vous promets sur écoute
et je vous promets sur la tête du
réalisateur de son émission ah ben non
moi je peux vous dire vous pouvez
l'appeler puis qu'ils viennent me voir
il lui dit bon il peut et déjà on vit
peut dire fait pris combien leur hymne
dit il peut même vous faire des comptes
gratuite pour que vous voyez comment il
fait après tout quoi qu'est ce qu'il a
dit ah oui que je veux faire quoi et des
courses comme on appelle ça faire baiser
fait voilà des wc alors monsieur moix et
wc j'ai fait pas mal à mâcher coursier
oui et non les wc moi j'ai fait à
l'armée quoi tu es bon bah ça s'était
accordé mais si je viens travailler
comme coursier à france 2 je viens pas
faire non plus l'entretien de vos
toilettes quand même faut peut-être pas
exagérer eh bien je ne crois pas là bas
non mais vous me demander de venir faire
des wc mais non gc oui je sais je sais d
essai oui des essais de quoi pas mais
non parce qu'il me dit vous pouvez le
prendre pour faire délecter non non ça
je sais pas les wc moi mais tu fais pas
les vestes et je vous dis on écoute et
non de toute façon je vous dis tout de
suite que vous pourriez pas travailler
avec moi parce que je m'énerve rai1
comprenez rien
[Musique]